the covet 19 pandemic has put the
spotlight on virologists
well right now but their star status
has also made them the target of public
anger
even death threats and people because of
their lack of trust and authority
would not want to take the vaccine
people think
that we want to shut the country down
anthony fauci has gained a huge
following
but not everyone you know biden wants to
lock it down he wants to listen to
dr fauci who wants to listen to dr
falcon
germany too has spawned its science
superstars
like christian rosten
his podcast is one of the most popular
in the country
[Music]
alexander kekoli is a regular guest on
german talk shows
he sparred with politicians over their
virus response at the beginning of the
crisis
but as social media memes feed the echo
chamber
are these new celebrities serving to
further polarize scientific debate
[Music]
well different views are vital in the
world of science
asking questions is key at the end of
the day people believe what they want to
believe
but should we trust science or the
scientist
they're only human and this crisis has
been full of
uncertainties still science is not about
certainties it's about constraining what
we don't know
some of the best-known virologists in
germany work here at the university
hospital in bonn
some refer to it as the strake institute
after its leader
researcher hendrick strake he's 43 years
old and well known in medical circles
thanks to his work in the fight against
hiv
but now researchers across europe know
his name
due to the coronavirus or sarskoff ii
pandemic
we added a concentration of the plasma
from a person who was infected with
cells too
and we can show that plasma can inhibit
the virus that the patient has developed
antibodies which can neutralize the
virus
since drugs hardly work against the
virus he is relying on the development
of a vaccine
when that will happen is unknown
there is cause for optimism because
we're currently doing so many vaccine
trials and so much research is being put
into it
so that if things go very well we can
have a vaccine in january
or later next year but history has
taught us that it sometimes takes years
or even decades until a vaccine is found
if or once one's found the mad rush will
be on
but will it be a case of richer
countries getting their hands on
it first leaving poorer nations to
struggle with the virus
when a vaccine is available i'm sure
that it will be available worldwide
especially in less developed countries
maybe even for free
there or at least at a very low cost
in the meantime testing is key the dank
lab has been using molecular pcr tests
that detect the genetic material from
the virus
and have results within hours antigen
tests
detect specific proteins on the surface
of the virus
they aren't as reliable but they're
faster
you can get the result within 15 minutes
which can be given directly to the
patient
and a highly infectious person can be
isolated and therefore
unable to infect others
how people get infected is something
researchers agree on
via microscopic particles spread by
breathing
so called aerosol particles at first it
was unclear whether people could get
infected from contaminated surfaces
for example someone could have just
sneezed into their hand
and then touched the doorknob and then
other people could touch
it and bring it straight up to the
mucous membranes
it's rare but it could happen
whether people can have multiple
infections has long been debated
can those who have recovered from
coronavirus become re-infected
or are they protected against getting
sick again
so far they've been over 40 million
infections worldwide but only five cases
of people who've been infected again
with the virus
this actually proves there's an immunity
gift artworks from africa are on display
in strakes office
for decades he's travelled the continent
he's worked in hospitals in uganda
and south africa it did sight in africa
the time i spent in africa showed me the
importance of vaccines and how much more
there is to research in this area
above all in his speciality hiv and now
though
in covid19 too with a view to the fight
against the coronavirus in
africa another less moment is a
professor of science communication and
linguistics at the kazuo institute
for technology in germany and it's a
immunity
masks and surfaces the the opinions are
wide ranging the advice
has changed dramatically does science
have a communication problem
i wouldn't say that this is a
communication problem it's a
communication
challenge why because science and
society science and politics
are very very distinct social systems
science is highly specialized experts
communicate
in very very specialized ways and their
methods and ways of working are highly
highly specialized so
it's intrinsically a challenge to
communicate about this
and this is what we know every day that
you need to connect with the public and
there are many ways of being
misunderstood
or making oneself not understandable in
this communication
why is it such a challenge just explain
to us what scientific assessment
actually is well
scientific assessment means what
sometimes in the public seems like
changing opinion all the time which is
actually in fact
um and highly and especially in corona
at times
very sped up involvement of
ideas so we wouldn't want
corona experts and kobit 19 experts to
tell us the same thing as
half a year ago this would be very very
old knowledge so
it's changing on very high speeds
and people collect data and um
assess data and can have different
assessments of
these data this is the normal thing that
in in science you can have
disputes and discussions on on findings
but if it's if it's changing all the
time in neta
how can we trust science that's
a very good question we need informed
trust blind trust would be
something like i i'm believing
everything uh what people say
this is not such a good idea but
informed trust would be
that we um look at um what kind of
expert do i have in front of me do i
have an
expert on let's look at myself science
communication so
maybe i can trust this person more than
someone
from another area who is talking about
science communication
and that's the same with virality
virology for example that um you might
want to listen to someone who is
actually studying this topic and not
for example an engineer another
criterion for informed trust
is benevolence so you look at um
is this person really interested in the
well-being in the welfare of society
or not but you're presuming that people
are listening and there are a lot of
people who don't seem to be listening to
science or the scientists
yeah this is a a big problem of course
because science communication is not
just about conveying
information it's about reaching out to
people and people
are very much driven by their identities
for example and their values so
if you're for example very much
fostering
um um a freedom and if you're
very much a free person and you're
saying
i'm not wanting anyone to tell me
anything about what i should do
or if i should put on a mask then it's
difficult to reach out
to these people then you have to talk
about values why is this so important
for you
so scientists sometimes also have to
talk about freedom
and identity and not about their
research
that's a lot to ask for mom and it's
less momentum
from the causeway institute for
technology thank you very much
time to let you ask the questions all
you have to do is send them to our
youtube channel
our science correspondent derek williams
will do the rest
can you tell us more about fomites and
how long the virus remains infectious on
surfaces
fomites are objects that are
contaminated by a sick person that can
pass an
infectious pathogen along to others
are thinking about them and the current
pandemic has evolved
a lot since the beginning of the year on
experts at the who
and and other health authorities now say
that fomites play
at most a secondary role in the in the
spread of kovic 19 and the general
consensus
is that that surface transmission might
be possible
but is likely pretty uncommon however
a few weeks ago a new study came out of
australia
that's drawn attention back to the
question of
how much danger fomites might
potentially
pose so let's take a look at it the
study sought to show
what effects different temperatures have
on viral viability on various surfaces
over time
and the result that raised eyebrows was
that at 20 degrees celsius
the researchers detected potentially
infectious virus
on some materials for up to 28 days
wow that's a long time for a surface to
remain potentially infectious right
but the thing is those experiments were
carried out under very
virus-friendly conditions for example
the viral laden test droplets that the
researchers used were
a standardized solution they weren't
mucus which is thought to be
a much more hostile environment for
pathogens and
and samples were also kept in the dark
the whole time because
uv light quickly deactivates sores cove
too
in other words though interesting the
results don't reflect
what happens in the real world which is
why
experts haven't changed recommendations
and and most remain convinced
that the role that surfaces play in
covet 19 transmission
is small
you